where the Niger Delta meets the Sahara
desert lies the ancient Citadel of
Timbuktu this UNESCO world heritage site
was a center of Islamic civilization in
the 11th century now it's under attack
by fighters from the al-Qaeda affiliate
jamaat Nusrat al-islam Muslim they're
trying to take over the city
today the situation is truly unbearable
the people of Timbuktu are suffering and
this is a cry from the heart
Al-Qaeda Fighters control the northern
roads leading to the city and are
blocking trucks carrying goods and
humanitarian Aid inside Timbuktu petrol
pumps are running empty prices of food
like potatoes and onions are now 10
times more expensive supplies of rice
sugar and Millet have all but
disappeared
the market is currently very difficult
because if it goes on like this a lot of
stores will close if foodstuffs like oil
milk sugar rice and Millet don't come in
normally it's going to be difficult for
the population
the UN peacekeeping mission in Mali is
shutting down its operation including in
Timbuktu at the request of the country's
government of transition the Prime
Minister says there is no peace for them
to keep the U.N warns of an unfolding
humanitarian crisis unfortunately this
Siege also have created a kind of Havoc
you know many people who can afford to
live to muktu live to muktu I mean we
have been alerted again and again by the
our office Universal office in
Mauritania where we have expecting we
are noticing the arrivals of a thousand
and thousands of Malian fleeing to
fleeing the region where today they
don't have kind of safe heaven in 2012
Al-Qaeda Fighters took control of
Timbuktu in the space of a few days they
destroyed ancient mausoleums set light
to a librarian burnt Islamic manuscripts
and ancient qurans that were hundreds of
years old a decade on they are back this
time they're better equipped and more
organized and they're tightening their
grip on the ancient city
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera